breaking overnight two people are dead
and five others are injured when a
gunman opened fire at a yoga studio in
Tallahassee Florida authorities say the
suspect died from an apparent
self-inflicted gunshot wound Kenneth
Craig has the latest on the details in
this Tallahassee complex a peaceful hot
yoga class was violently interrupted
Friday night when a shooter entered and
opened fire I've seen a lot of bad
scenes and seen some bad things this is
the worst two women died from their
wounds 21 year old Mara Binkley and 62
year old dr. Nancy Van vessel four
additional victims were hospitalized
another man was pistol-whipped after he
tried to confront the alleged gunman the
fact that we had people fight this
attacker and prevent him from doing
further harm really I think speaks to
the true spirit of Tallahassee Melissa
Hutchinson tens bar across the street
she administered first aid as bloodied
victims rushed inside to take cover
they were very emotional they just saw
people get shot police say the suspect
is Scott Bierly he had two previous
arrests in Tallahassee both for battery
authorities haven't identified a motive
in response to the shooting Tallahassee
mayor Andrew Gilliam and Florida
Governor Rick Scott visited gunshot
victims in the hospital the truth is is
that these occurrences have become far
too frequent in our society and it's my
sincere hope that obviously beyond this
will all reflect on why that might be
for CBS this morning Saturday I'm
Kenneth Craig